hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast new tools for
understanding allosteric signaling in
g-protein coupled receptors presented by
Matthew Eddy PhD a postdoctoral research
fellow at the Scripps Research Institute
I'm Juli O'Rourke of leopards and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots leopards is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want any time you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or you can use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the
accreditation button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me in
welcoming dr. Eddie I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you very
much so today I'm excited to talk to you
about my research and specifically about
mechanisms of allosteric signaling and
human GPCRs so to provide an overview of
what I'm going to present today first
I'm going to provide an introduction to
human GPCRs in a brief overview of their
structure function and physiological
relevance and then I want to tell you a
little bit about their relevance for
drug discovery the second and third
topics are belong under the same
umbrella and that is integrative
structural biology techniques to study
gpcr structure and function in the first
of these two we'll be talking about
allosteric communication and human gpcrs
studied by x-ray crystallography and
specifically the role of an alux
allosteric Center is studied by x-ray
crystallography and the third and final
section we're going to be talking about
allosteric communication with human
GPCRs as studied by NMR spectroscopy and
specifically I will tell you about how
solution nuclear magnetic resonance or
NMR reveals allosteric pathways and
human GPCRs so first I'd like to provide
an overview of
gpcrs structure and function or
g-protein coupled receptors on this
slide you see a cartoon of the cell
surface in which the lipid bilayer is
represented by these gray rectangles and
the GPCR is shown here in a red cartoon
of passing through that lipid bilayer on
the cell surface it has a seven
transmembrane or 7tm architecture on
inside of the cell below the
intracellular surface you see also a
trimeric g-protein complex which I will
describe its interactions with the GPC
are on the following slide now the basic
scheme of action for human GPCRs at the
cell surface proceeds as follows so we
have a small molecule in this case
adrenaline it's recognized by the ji pzr
and it binds to it causing a
conformational change to happen on the
intracellular surface this change
enables complex formation with the
trimeric g-protein that facilitates
exchange between GTP and gdp shown here
this exchange then breaks apart this
trimeric g protein complex into two
subunits that each activate signaling
Cascades this ultimately results in a
physiological
of consequence now in humans we have
over we have eight hundred and twenty
six different GPCRs all of which play
critical roles and human health and
diseases and here are just some examples
of the areas where human GPCRs impact
physiology and health so our vision is
mediated by rhodopsin which is a human
GPC our cardiovascular health is
mediated by a number of different GPCRs
including adrenergic receptors which are
responsible for the fight-or-flight
mechanism adenosine receptors and so on
allergies are mediated by histamine
receptors metabolic health and illnesses
are also mediated by gpcrs immune system
function a gpcrs play a critical role in
this as well as critical roles and how
diseases hijack and take advantage of
our immune systems and GPCRs played
critical roles and the health of the
central nervous system including a
feeling or of pain so GPCRs are really
how we interact with our environment
around us are responsible for our sight
our small vessel factory receptors taste
taste receptors um even the way we think
and feel and consciousness itself may be
mediated by human GPCRs human gpcrs are
also major drug targets and on this
slide you see some examples of some of
the most widely used and perhaps abused
drugs that target BP scars so we have
caffeine present and coffee
theobromine which is present and
chocolate and theophylline a present in
tea now in terms of drug discovery G
bazaars have historically been a very
popular target for treating and
illnesses and developing new drugs to
treat diseases so currently about 35 to
40 percent of fda-approved drugs target
human g-protein couple
actors there have been 116 GPCR targeted
drugs approved in the last 20 years and
there appears to be no decline in the
success of human gpcr drug discovery of
projecting forward out of those 826
unique human gpcrs so far only 43 has
been successfully targeted for drug
discovery thus there are remaining many
many potential gpcrs that could be a
great target for treating new diseases
on this slide you see just a few
examples of a number of commercial
fda-approved drugs probably many of you
are taking one or more of these
currently so GPCRs are major major drug
targets and will continue to be so and
since we're talking about drugs it's
useful to talk about what they actually
do in terms of affecting the gpcr
function and structure and we typically
classified GPCR drugs or ligands
according to their function or efficacy
and so on here um all GPCRs have what we
call a basal level of signaling and this
is represented on the left side of the
slide and you see a kind of + straight
line that goes across from the left to
the right of the chart now some drugs
are known as neutral antagonists and so
they will bind and be recognized by GP
stars but they don't change the level of
basal signaling some drugs are bind to
gpcrs and activate the GPCR or they
increase that level of signaling we call
these agonists and there you can either
have a full agonist which leads to for
maximal activation or a partial agonist
which is a drug that binds to the
receptor causing sub maximal activation
and finally the last class of ortho
start binding drugs are known as inverse
agonist
in which we bind to the GPCR and they
actually lower the level of signaling
below the basal level of activity so now
with this what is the consequence of
these drugs binding to the receptor
terms of their structure always solved a
number of different GPCR structures with
x-ray crystallography of four different
kinds of drugs of different efficacies
and here are just two examples now here
we have on the right side of the slide
at the top as a side view of a
superposition of two crystal structures
of the adenosine a 2a receptor this is
in complex with an antagonist and then
also in complex with an agonist and on
the bottom you see a superposition of
the same two structures from the
intracellular view here indicating the
change in the orientation of the Gila
sees differences in the efficacies of
the ligand this is this change and the
orientation of these gila sees in this
motion is what leads to an enabled
complex formation with the intracellular
g-protein partner now one of the
questions that really intrigued me is
what the mechanism of allosteric
communication between the drug binding
pocket and the intracellular surface so
on this slide we see an example of a
GPCR g-protein complex and the drug is
shown in a space-filling representation
on towards the top of the blue GPCR near
the extracellular surface so the
distance between that binding site and
the site on the intracellular surface
where the g-protein forms a complex with
the GPCR is about 30 angstroms away
which is which is quite a far distance
on a microscopic scale so it's a great
interest to me out of this gnome is
propagated through the receptor
these conformational changes on the
intracellular surface of the receptor
ultimately leading to complex formation
with the partner protein inside of the
cell and that's what motivated my
research now I want to get into the
heart of present um new research
attempting to answer this question and
first I'm going to talk about
Alastor communication and human GPC is a
study by x-ray crystallography and in
particularly the role of an allosteric
Center as study by x-ray crystallography
and for this work we focused on one
particular GPCRs called human adenosine
a to a receptor or a to a AR now the
adenosine a to a receptor is one of the
main targets for caffeine theobromine
and theophylline the drugs that I had
mentioned on an earlier slide in
addition to that it's also responsible
for mediating myocardial blood flow
dopamine release an immune system
relation it's a validated target for
treating Parkinson's disease and it's
currently being explored by different
companies as a cancer communal therapy a
target as well so it's really important
for human health and disease on the
right you see an example of a crystal
structure of the human adenosine a 2a
receptor shown in green PDB 3e and al
here you'll notice that there's the 70 M
or trans membrane architecture with the
ligand bound to the top in the
orthostatic binding pocket addition to
that toward the bottom of the structure
on the left hand side you'll notice
there's a an additional protein domain
this domain is not president naturally
and is added in order to crystallize the
receptor to obtain its structure I'll
talk about a little bit about the
consequences of this in subsequent
slides now
question of how signals are propagated
through the receptor there's a second
clue that we wanted to focus on the role
of a particular residue in an allosteric
Center
this is aspartic acid 52 on the left is
a crystal structure a high-resolution
one pointing angstrom crystal structure
of the human a 2a receptor and you'll
see all these red tears the red spheres
are crystallographic water now if we
expand the central region and the
structure in the center of this slide
you'll see there are several recipes
that form coordinated bonds with these
waters as well as with the blue sir at
the center which is a sodium ion
aspartic acid 52 is at the bottom of
this cluster and this residue is highly
conserved among all Class A gpcrs which
is the rhodopsin class of gpcrs and
which is a majority of gpcrs now
something like 85% or more different
class a GP series hath aspartic acid 52
this charged residue if they don't they
typically have another charged residues
such as glutamic acid in its place so
it's highly conserved now if we replace
this aspartic acid 52 with the neutral
asparagine this leads to a variant
protein with some interesting properties
so on the left is a cartoon showing that
for the wild-type or native on a to a
onor when an agonist or ligand binds to
the receptor we get g-protein signaling
as a consequence of that for this
particular variant g50 and it doesn't
perturb ligand binding so ligands bind
like they would for the native protein
but there's absolutely no g-protein
signaling so you can bind an agonist and
g-protein signaling is complete killed
for this variant
in this phenomena is also widely
observed and then reported for other
gpcrs with this particular variant so it
seems pretty cool that this is involved
with signaling pathways and not just
that made to a receptor but other Class
A GPC is as well now the cartoon on the
previous slide is also supported on this
slide which is showing the actual data
so on left you can see on radio ligand
binding data so we have we take a drug
it's labeled with tritium and observe
its binding activity or affinity for a
particular target in this case we looked
at in agonist and you can see that the
data we measure for the wild-type
protein is almost identical for this
special D 52 and variant protein whereas
on the right we have a g-protein
signaling assay and so you can engrave
the native protein when we add an
agonist we get a response an upward
response on this agonist efficacy curve
indicating g-protein signaling whereas
for the D 52 and variant we get no
signaling whatsoever even with very high
concentration of agonist together with
my co-author Kate white we solved 2.5
angstrom crystal structure with variant
protein HK Rd 52 n in complex with an
agonist which was recently published in
the journal structure and this complex
is shown as presented here so you can
see it has the 70 M architecture like we
would expect and the ligand is shown
found onto the top of the receptor and a
vertical binding post now what's
interesting is if we compare this
crystal structure with the native
protein and complex with the same
agonist and with a ligand of different
pharmacology efficacy on the Left we see
a side of the variant protein D 52 n and
complex with this agonist
UK four three two zero nine seven and
that's the superb superimposed over the
structure of the native place with an
antagonist as in yellow um and you can
see that there is subtle differences
between the two on the right we have a
superposition of the variant protein in
complex with agonist again on
superimposed with the native and in
complex with the same agonist and the
structures are essentially identical in
this view so that comparison um is a
little bit better illustrated in this
rmsd plot of the superposition of the
two proteins and so you can see at the
top in the top panel when we're
comparing the differences between the
structures there's essentially no
difference except for a region on that
is local to the site of the mutation and
that's expanded in the lower box there
so this is residue steering a seven dot
46 that you see mainly in 7.47 uh and so
on so there we see the largest
structural deviations between the
variant protein d 52 N and the native
protein it turns out that that region
that we see the largest difference is
close to a conserved activation of motif
that is conserved among the most classic
gpcrs it's called the NP x XY activation
motif and in this slide here we're
looking at several different conserved
activation motifs which I won't get into
in detail the important point is the one
that's highlighted um in cyan on the
lower right is the N P XY motif which is
where we actually see structural
deviations now in the bottom figure this
is a cartoon representing hydrogen bonds
between five of the seven HeLa C's near
this activation of microswitch region
and the structure this cartoon is
compared changes in height
bonding so on the Left we have hydrogen
bonding for the antagonist complex in
which you see we have hydrogen bonds
between helix 1 & 7 & 2 & 7 and you can
contrast that to the middle diagram
where we see changes in the hydrogen
bonding between key lessees 7 & 6 & 2 &
3 & & & hydrogen bonding observed for
the agonist complex with the variant
protein D 52 n in which we see a kind of
hype on between the two so um
publication of hydrogen bonding observed
from the antagonist complex and a little
bit of hydrogen bonding observed from
Agnes complex so between HeLa C's 2 & 3
so this changes in hydrogen bonding we
propose contribute to differences in
signaling between the two proteins
however what was interesting also was
the fact that the structures were so
highly similar now on this slide here
and has the same superpositions of the
variant D 52 in agonist protein complex
with the antagonist complex shown on the
left and a superposition with the native
protein agonist complexion on the Ray
and the bottom two figures are again
intracellular views so inside the cell
looking up at super positions of the two
proteins on the Left we see changes in
the relative orientations of the Keela
C's on the right we see actually no
change whatsoever now this is
interesting because at the intracellular
surface there is no signaling observed
for the D 52 and variant protein whereas
the native protein does signal so from
this view the two structures are the
same and in that respect don't fully
explain the differences that we see with
the data so that motivated us to think
about the role of conformational
Amyx and its relationship to GPCR
function and tribute to introduce this
topic I really like this quote from
Richard Fineman who says everything that
living things do can be understood in
terms of the jiggling and wiggling of
atoms and here we have a comparison of
some of the strengths between extra
crystallography and online
whereas x-ray crystallography can give
us very high resolution information on
the information is of a single
conformational state whereas NMR
spectroscopy with NMR spectroscopy we
can observe multiple confirmations that
are simultaneously populated and in
equilibrium so with that I would like to
come to the third point of the
presentation being investigating a
lestrade communication in human GPCRs by
NMR spectroscopy and in particular I'm
going to talk about how solution NMR
spectroscopy reveals allosteric pathways
in the human adenosine a 2a receptor now
when I had started my postdoctoral
studies with Ray Stevens and Curt boot
rich this was this slide represents some
examples of state of the art at the time
of studies of human GPCRs so on the left
for example um there was studies using
fluorine and Ammar spectroscopy to study
the beta-2 adrenergic receptor this is
one example from the loot rich lab um
using a flowing NMR about one
dimensional simple one-dimensional NMR
experiments to study bias signaling in
the human beta-2 adrenergic receptor on
the right there is a technique using
reductive methylation that was first
published on in its relevancy to
studying human JP stars by the kabocha
group this is an exam
of the kind of data on that was obtained
with this method and so license could be
methylated with a carbon 13 ch3 group
and thereby study with NMR spectroscopy
so what these studies had in common is
that they typically introduced isotopic
labels which are necessary for NMR
spectroscopy as a kind of post
translational modification and the
reasons for that are really that um
first production and purification of
human GP studies is challenging
regardless of whatever technique you use
to study its structure function and
dynamics on the second that
incorporation of the stable isotopes
required for NMR spectroscopy is also
challenging and adds further
difficulties to the experiments so my
own research and interest is in trying
to expand the number of NMR probes that
we use to study gpcrs in order to
provide a more comprehensive view of
gpcrs structure and function this is
illustrated by this cartoon on this
slide so we had seen a number of
different gpci studies where there were
a few probes introduced by chemical
modification or a kind of post
translational modification
this has well-established biochemical
methods however it provides less
comprehensive view of signaling and what
I'm interested in is providing a more
comprehensive view on by introducing NMR
probes through biosynthetic
incorporation so this is a more
challenging for a number of reasons but
we typically take the approach of
uniform incorporation of stable nitrogen
15 carbon 13 and deuterium oxide SOI
deuterium isotopes um directly into the
GPC are expressions media
and for this we're expressing our
protein and yeast or pichia pastoris
most of the crystallography and other
structural studies done on human GP
starters have expressed the receptor in
either insect or mammalian cell systems
because of that we wanted to carefully
characterize the material that we
express to make sure that its function
and fold and properties were identical
to the same a protein expressed in
insect or mammalian cell systems on the
left you see some representative radio
ligand binding assays indicating that we
observe native-like ligand binding for
the receptor expressed in yeast
membranes as compared to mammalian cell
expression systems on the right in the
bottom right you see an example
analytical size exclusion chromatography
trace of isotopically labeled human a to
a a are expressly nice just prior to NMR
studies so we see essentially a single
well resolved component indicating a
homogeneous and mono dispersed sample on
the top right you see these are
so-called fluorescence thermal shift
assays which we use to indirectly
monitor ligand binding to a GPCRs so
these s-shaped curves you see shift to
the right
indicating ligand binding to the
receptor increasing its melting
temperature indirectly also validating
the ligand binding assays now on this
slide
unfortunately this slide looks a little
bit um distorted the main point is that
we directly monitored radio ligand
binding of the samples that we prepared
for NMR studies in the conditions used
for NMR studies and that being a 2 AAA
are reconstituting
into detergent micelles so we used
scintillation proximity assays and
directly measured the ligand binding of
the of several different ligands to the
receptor on in the same conditions used
for my studies and we could validate
that the protein retained its
native-like function and the same
conditions we used for all of our
experiments
now we further we further validated our
system by expressing a so-called gpcr
diffusion construct in pichia pastoris
the same strain that we were using for
production for animal studies and we
crystallized that protein so some of the
crystals of that are shown on the left
and on the right you see a superposition
of the structure of the a2 aar fusion
protein in complex with an antagonist
and it's superimposed with an earlier
structure of the same protein as
expressed in insect cells and overall
the two were essentially identical now
importantly for NMR studies we did not
use a fusion protein there were no
stabilizing point mutations introduced
in the receptor the protein is
reconstituted into mixed my cells
containing cholesterol and E succinate
that retain native-like binding
properties as demonstrated by religion
binding assays now after much
optimization of a number of different
conditions used for expressing the
protein as well as for obtaining NMR
data we were able to obtain a very high
resolution solution NMR data for the
adenosine a 2a receptor shown on this
slide is a representative NMR spectrum
this is at rosy spectrum as measured at
800 megahertz in which we see over 270
individually results signals and this
was recorded with only a few milligrams
of protein
um in less than a day at 800 megahertz
without a cryoprobe now as a point of
reference I present the spectrum from
the previous slide and compare that to
some published NMR data from the
gerhardt vogner laboratory uh in which
they measured prosy NMR spectra of a
protein expressed in e.coli this is
bacteria rhodopsin which is also a 7tm
protein but not a GPCR and you can see
at first glance the quality of the two
spectra are comparable indicating that
we have again very high quality high
resolution NMR data that we can use to
learn something new about the protein so
why did we use pichia pastoris and go to
such great effort to validate the
expression system and the reason is
simple we can incorporate eight
deuterium oxide into the expression
media um for yeast so he's tolerate high
levels of D to O and the D to O is
necessary to obtain the high-resolution
spectra that you see so on this slide we
compare the effects of a uniformly
nitrogen 15 labeled sample with and
without due duration in the top spectrum
you can see this is the native a to a AR
without due duration and in the bottom
spectrum the only difference here is
that this spectrum was reported for a
protein with Dew duration so this are
motivated this is the motivation for you
say the yeast expression system so now
that we have this nice end of my data of
the adenosine a 2a receptor we want to
be able to identify an assign some of
those well resolved signals and each one
of those signals that is arising from
an individual approach on nitrogen error
and in order to assign and identify them
on we took an approach where we first
aren't characterized we looked at the
NMR spectrum and in particular focused
focus on two characteristic regions so
one is the tryptophan endo region which
is located in the lower left and the
other is a glycine backbone region which
tends to appear towards the top of the
NMR spectrum in order to assign these
signals we used amino acid replacement
and thereby replacing one by one a
glycine with an alanine or a tryptophan
with a halogen or a tyrosine the summary
of all of those experiments are shown on
the right-hand side of this slide so you
can see for example for tryptophan 29
which is located toward the top of the
panel of data we would place that with a
tyrosine and we were able to then
unambiguously assign the signal from
defend 29 that way
as indicated by the start and the traces
through the NMR data in each panel by
doing so we were able to assign all six
tryptophans
located on the extracellular and
intracellular surfaces as well as the
membrane spanning regions and we were
also able to further and 6 or spy on
eight glycines
distributed on the extracellular surface
and intracellular surface including at a
key location on the intracellular end of
helix 6 as you remember from the title
slide there was a picture of the
receptor with lanterns hung in key
positions and this was a motivation for
that picture suggesting that each one of
these lanterns is an endpoint probe
lighting up
structural regions of the receptor and
all together providing a compliment you
of the protein now that we have assigned
and identified these signals and start
to ask questions about how do the an
amide data or signals respond to changes
in drug efficacy so on this slide you
see on the left we have panels from
two-dimensional rosianna my experiments
in which each panel we have focused on
the end of tryptophan region of the
spectrum for six different complexes so
three complexes with antagonists shown
on the left and three complexes with
agnes shown on the right and these boxes
dashed and dotted boxes are important as
well and we'll get to them on the next
slide so if you just compare it for
example at the top of this panel of six
with data with the antagonists and
echinus complexes we see changes in the
peak shapes as well as their positions
or chemical shifts indicating responses
variable drug efficacy or changes in
drug efficacy and we can better
visualize some of those responses by
looking at projections so on this slide
we have projections through the boxes
that I showed on the previous slide and
we have the signals on assigned and
annotated in each of these boxes so at
the top you can see there's data
projections for the tryptophan signals
for the complex with the antagonist cm2
four one three eight five now
it is interesting to compare are the
shape and intensities of signals between
the tryptophan zon the intracellular
surface versus the extracellular surface
so you can see the signals for
tryptophan 29 there are actually two of
them and they're much broader compared
to the signal for tryptophan 143 which
is located on the extracellular surface
which shows a single signal that is
relatively narrower than what's observed
for tryptophan 29
you'll also notice for the complexes
with antagonists so there are two
examples in the bottom of this panel its
Mecca and UK for three two oh nine seven
so tryptophan 32 for those complexes on
actually we observe two components and
the signal for tryptophan 32 and overall
the signal is broader than that's what's
observed for tryptophans on the
extracellular surface so this broadening
or signal multiplicity is due to the
presence of multiple simultaneously
populated conformers uh that are local
and in exchange we can also now look at
the glycine which we've assigned and see
how they respond to variable drug
efficacy or changes in drug efficacy and
this slide just shows some examples of
that kind of comparison we can make so
for example at the top you'll see data
of for glycine 118 which is located on
the intracellular surface um at the end
of helix 4 and we see large changes
there in chemical shift or position of
the NMR signal that it directly depends
on the efficacy of the bound drug we
also see changes for glycine 142 which
is located on the intracellular surface
as well as well as changes for glycine
218 and 114 and I will get further into
detail for those in the substance
slides as it relates to a function what
was one of the more interesting
observations again was for glycine 118
which is located at the entrance
cellular surface of helix 4 and we saw
large changes and chemical shifts for
the signals for glycine 118 indicating
differences in the backbone conformation
locally near advicing 118 for that
depends in a ligand efficacy dependent
manner so this was interesting because
actually if you look at the crystal
structures of the adenosine a 2a
receptor and focus on the region that's
local to placing 118 there are
essentially no differences on between
those structures whereas the animai data
indicate that there are 100 differences
that are observed
for the solution experiments indicating
that aniline may provide some additional
insight into changes in structure
bitterness with crystallography now
perhaps one of the most interesting
observations was made with tryptophan to
46 which is known in the GPCR literature
as a toggle switch tryptophan going back
to studies of rhodopsin it turns out
that tryptophan - 46 is a highly
sensitive probe of drug efficacy in the
human adenosine a 2a receptor on the
left you see two-dimensional rosey NMR
spectra focusing on the region where we
identify tryptophan - 46 in the top
spectrum for the complex with the
antagonist CM 2 for 1 3 8 5 you see the
location of tryptophan - 46 is indicated
on by the line toward the right side of
the window in the bottom spectrum we
have a complex with bit
agonized NECA and in this complex we've
assigned the signal for tryptophan to 46
which is all the way over on the left
side lower left side of the of the
window roughly about 1 ppm difference in
chemical shifts between the two
complexes this is a very large efficacy
dependent chemical shift that's observed
for this toggle switch tryptophan and
what is the rationale for this large
chemical shift well when you look at the
crystal structures of the adenosine into
a receptor there's a nearby
phenylalanine ring and there's a
well-known phenomena in NMR spectroscopy
so-called ring current Jess so if you
have an aromatic group that is nearby an
NMR probe the relative position and
orientation of that aromatic group can
have a significant effect on the
chemical shift of the observed and the
my probe and this goes back quite a long
ways in NMR spectroscopy as illustrated
here on the on the right in this cartoon
the changes of the orientation and
position of the ring relatives banana
mark probe can have pronounced effects
on the chemical shift of that probe so
we can also see that we observe similar
changes when we compare other complexes
so again the top two panels are between
the antagonist GM an agonist NECA the
bottom again is for the antagonist ex-ac
which has a different scaffold of an
agonist of CGS 21 680 so structurally
the origins of this large change that we
see are due to nearby phenylalanine ring
242 and its position relative to the
toggle switch tryptophan to 46 what's
really exciting is that this
phenylalanine 242 as part of a conserved
activation motif called the pif
activation motif consisting of a prolene
189 isoleucine 92 infidelity 242 so the
relative changes in the confirmation of
activation Latif and changes of the
position and chemical shift of the
interval signal for tryptophan to 46
now this pif activation motif is highly
conserved on the Ray is a figure from
previous paper from the Stevens lab
first indicating the importance of this
activation motif and showing how the
local confirmation of these residues
change between structures of with
ligands of different efficacies and we
propose that this observation may be
useful to study a number of different
human GPCRs for example recently the
resolved crystal structures of the human
cannabinoid receptor and complex with
tons of different efficacies so shown
here are super positions of a CB 1 in
complex with an agonist and antagonist
and operable to do so called toggle
switch tryptophan is shown here on an
expansion of this where it undergoes a
large
reorientation between the two complexes
which we would anticipate would also we
would also see a large change in that
chemical shift of that toggle switch
tryptophan so this observation could
likely be extended to other classic
GPCRs as well so this brings me back to
the central question of signal
transduction in GPCRs and in particular
what is special about this aspartic acid
52 and why the this amino acid
replacement D 52 n permits ligand
binding and then kills D protein
signaling and this slide is just a
reminder of that of that behavior that
we see for the variant protein now when
we look at this auto switch tryptophan
and compare the data between
the native protein in the variant D 52m
we see some interesting differences so
on the Left the blue spectrum that you
see are for the native protein and we
see the location of the toggle switch
tryptophan as shown on the earlier slide
on the right now we independently
assigned the toggle switch tryptophan
for complexes with antagonists and
agonist and we see that the position or
chemical shift of this toggle switch
tryptophan is different indicating local
differences and the relative orientation
of this toggle switch tryptophan to that
pif activation micro switch also now if
we if you remember on an earlier slide
we were looking at some of the signals
from the tryptophan residues on the
intracellular surface and saw line
broadening signal multiplicity there so
if we look at those same tryptophan
signals and compare the data for the
native and the variant proteins we see
some interesting differences so this
slide shows a comparison of that data so
on the left you have the native protein
and complex with an antagonist as the
blue spectrum and the agonist that's the
black spectrum below it now comparing
two complexes for the same ligands with
the variant protein D 50 to N and these
boxes that you see here these - boxes
armed with a data now our regions where
we took projections of these signals
these projections are shown on the far
right of the of the data and which you
see the signal multiplicity and broad
signal for tryptophan 29 for the native
protein whereas we see a large increase
in signal intensity um for the variant
protein D 50 to N and you can contrast
that for the signal that we observed for
tryptophan 143 which is essentially the
same
between the native protein and the
variant protein and now below that we
see similar effect for the complex um
with agonist whereas we see a very broad
signal of 1029 for the agonist complex
with the native protein we see a much
larger signal and much more intense
signal for the tryptophan 29 complex
with the variant protein indicating that
we have altered dynamics at the
intracellular surface but the
conformation near the drug binding
pocket is preserved because we don't see
differences for assigned signals on the
extracellular surface um and now this
data is also recapitulated where we see
for glycine 218 which is located on the
intracellular surface we see large
changes between the native protein and
variant protein for the same living
complexes so again the colors of the
spectra are the same and the boxes
indicate projections around the signal
and you can see um in the projection
panels we see large changes in the
signal multiplicity and intensities
between the native protein and the
variant protein indicating we also have
a change in conformational dynamics at
that location on intracellular surface
of helix 6 which normally under gives
large conformational changes between
active and inactive states so in this
slide here we have a summary of the
effects that we see for inactivation of
this allosteric switch mat onto the NMR
probes distributed throughout the a 2
aar so at the intracellular surface we
essentially see a native-like response
to ligand efficacy or no change
tryptophan to 46 which is located just
above on this day 52 site we have an
altered relative confirmation of the
sidechain of tryptophan to 46 with
respect to this conserved
pif activation motif and then of the
intracellular surface we have abolished
or altered conformational dynamics so in
this study we connect changes and the
local structural environment around the
toggle switch tryptophan to 46 with
changes in the conformational dynamics
at the intracellular surface this is
summarized in this cartoon where we show
effects of a lestrade switch mat on 2a
2a a are on the left we have the native
protein which ligand binding is
signaling is mediated through tryptophan
2 46 and we observed some strong
coupling between aspartic acid 52 and
this toggle switch tryptophan it's
coupled to conformational dynamics
observed at the intracellular surface as
indicated by the small arrows on between
the two yellow balls on the
intracellular surface for the variant
protein D 52 n what we see is that this
coupling is changed between the toggle
switch tryptophan and asparagine 52 this
leads to a loss of conformational
dynamics at the intracellular surface
and that correlates directly with a loss
of signaling activity for the variant
protein so in summary we've established
a platform for stable isotope labeling
of human gpcrs and we've used it to look
at one key problem but many more
additional questions could be addressed
excuse me could be addressed with this
technique we've been able to map a
select conformational changes in the
human a to aar and provide a more
comprehensive global view of those
changes and we've been able to relate
signaling are changes in signaling to
changes in conformational dynamics at
the intracellular surface which are
linked to local structural
rearrangements around tryptophan 2:46
with respect to this P I have activation
microswitch with that I would like to
thank my advisers on professor Kurt lute
rich at the Scripps Research Institute
professor Ray Stevens at USC as well as
a number of my colleagues at both
locations and collaborators Ken Jacobson
and Zhang Google at the National
Institutes of Health as well as funding
from the American diet II for a
postdoctoral fellowship and with that
ability to take any of your questions
thank you dr. Reddy for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar so if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is will
this new approach be able to tell us
more about GPCR complexes with drugs
that have not been crystallized yes
that's a great question so most GPCR
drugs are very difficult to cope
crystallized with gpcrs so because we
can get now site specific structural
inspection of a human gpcr we're not
limited and what we study - against a
very high affinity which are typically
used for crystallization studies in fact
we can look at ligands have affinity as
low as in the millimolar range so we
should be able to use this technique to
get information about the conformation
of the receptor in complex with Wiggins
then crystallized the data with the hua
under no scene receptor are fantastic
hell you extend this technique to
studying other human GPCRs in the future
well we're optimistic that the pichia
expression system can be used to express
other gpcrs others some precedents for
this in the literature where people have
systematically
screened expression levels of different
GPCRs in yeast or pichia pastoris in
addition to that other techniques are
emerging from other research groups of
where by they're able to incorporate
stable isotope labeling into insect or
mammalian cell expression systems as
well so that may also open up additional
duper's for future NMR studies of
different human gpcrs we have time for
one last question you are able to
identify and assign a subset of the
signals from the NMR theta can gain
further insight from the other as you
have to be assigned signals yes so one
of the powerful reasons this approaches
exciting is that we can use the other
signals even if we don't yet have their
identity to confirm the folded nests or
three-dimensional confirmation of the
receptor in addition to that we're
pursuing additional techniques using
more sophisticated spectroscopy as well
as including carbon-13 labeling to be
able to assign even more of the signals
that you saw um that will give us a
denser network of NMR probes that will
allow us to UM better and better refine
our view of signaling and signaling
pathways in GPC is well thank you again
i would like to once again thank dr.
eddie for his presentation i would also
like to thank lab roots for making
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 22nd 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know in the webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event that
is all for now thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again soon
goodbye